Oh, where am I?
Hello, everybody!
Oh, there I am!
Okay, here we go.
Hello, everybody.
That's a little awkward.
It's like, where did I go?
Oh, it's been so long.
It's been so long.
I'm trying to remember what my sound settings were.
That's how long it's been.
I don't even remember what my sound settings were.
Okay, I think it was... I know, like, what my... I know what my...
My Marvel ride was sound settings, right?
Oh, that's awkward.
I'm sorry.
That's just a little awkward.
I don't... I don't remember how to play in first person.
Oh my god.
You account based on... Oh my god, it's like...
Even the game knows it's been a long time.
Even the game was like, alright, let me give you a tutorial on how all of this works.
It's so weird.
Oh, it can't be... Oh man, I haven't played in first person in a...
Wow, that's where the settings were?
And then the progression?
Whoa, wowie.
Okay, so... Oh, this is weird.
It's like... I take up the whole screen now.
Like, it's so tiny.
It's so tiny.
Everything is so weird.
Okay, let's go to the... So, they changed a lot of shit, apparently.
That's why I'm back, guys.
All I know is about the mistress.
Welcome home, cheater.
Oh my god.
My first person.
Wait, did it reset my settings?
Is that how long I haven't played this game?
Give me a sec.
My settings are wrong.
What the fuck?
Okay, give me a sec.
Alright, let's see.
Oh my god, I haven't played in so long that my settings aren't even mine anymore.
Oh my god, everything is reset.
I was like, wait a minute, this isn't right.
These settings aren't correct.
Wait a minute.
Okay, let's see.
Let me check if I have...
Oh man, I don't know.
Okay, I got... Okay, I don't even remember what my settings were.
I don't even remember.
Okay, it's like that, and then the bhop, and then...
Where's melee?
And... Wait, what was... Okay, that.
It was...
Change weapons.
Cycle weapons was this.
Yes, I think so.
Oh man.
Was that how I cycled?
Oh my god, give me... Guys, give me... It's not looking so good.
It's not... I'm trying to remember what my settings were.
I must have saved it somewhere.
Oh my god.
Okay, Apex settings.
I must have saved my keybinds somewhere, right?
Oh my god, there's no way I didn't save my keybinds.
I will be so sad.
I will actually... I don't remember.
I legitimately... I don't remember.
It's been so long.
I... I actually... What do I... What was my...
Did I use mouse bind for cycle weapon?
Oh my god, this is really bad.
This is... This is so bad.
Did I... Guys, guys, I'm... Guys, give me a sec.
I need a... I need a remember.
Okay.
Okay, I cycle... No, that's not...
That's the old one because I can tap strafe now.
So, okay, I think...
I think these are my settings.
I think... I think they're my settings because I don't talk to people.
Okay, let me make sure everything else is okay.
Let me make sure.
Okay, weapon, mini map.
Okay, on, ping.
Okay, enemy.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Taking damage.
Okay, off, off.
I need to make sure everything I need is okay.
Okay, I think it's all... I think it's good now.
I think we are okay.
I don't know.
Everything is a blur right now, but I think everything will be okay.
Sound guy, I need you to know if the sound is okay because I don't know.
Okay, oh my god.
Am I... Okay, wait.
Wait, where's the... I'm at... Oh, wait.
Was I always at 100?
What's default, guys?
Guys, what's default?
Guys, what's the FOV default?
I can't remember.
What's the FOV default?
I need a... Was I on 100?
Have I always been on 100?
I don't remember.
I actually don't.
Oh my god.
What's wrong with me?
I've played these games for so long.
How do I just not remember?
Okay.
Oh my god.
I forgot what it's like to shoot in first person.
It's crazy.
I have like almost... I think I have 2K hours in this game and then like... It's just that easy.
It feels so weird.
Did I actually... Yes, okay.
Okay, I did use this.
Like... Oh my god.
I don't remember what it was like to shoot in first person.
It's actually so weird to shoot in first person again.
Oh my god.
Okay, here we go.
Okay, I fixed all my settings.
It's been a while.
My settings reverted itself.
Oh my god.
We danced for so long.
I'm trying to...
Do you remember... Yeah, I still remember tap strafe, right?
Yeah, see?
That's tap strafing.
Look guys, I can tap strafe!
Wow!
That's 8K!
I can still do it!
Wow!
I can still do it at least.
Okay, now the wall bounce.
What is this?
Like the Apex 101?
Okay, wait shit.
Okay, give me a sec.
I didn't have momentum.
There we go.
Wait a minute.
Look at that.
Oh my god.
I'm back.
Boom!
Bhop, bhop's easy.
Look at that.
I still got it.
First try.
Oh my god, everything is so new.
It feels so close to me.
Like the training dummies feel so close.
They're like... I'm like, what are you doing here?
Why can't I see myself?
Okay, I don't know.
I think it's too loud, right?
Is the sound effects too loud?
Like, oh my god.
Like I said, I don't remember what my actual sound settings were for Apex.
It's been a while.
Check your scope and needs.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
Okay, I heard the R9 is sort of back, but I don't know.
We'll see how I feel.
I don't know if it's actually back or not.
But they buff everything.
So like, what else did they change, guys?
I heard they buffed every gun possible.
So like, the Havoc is crazy fucking insane now, apparently.
Give me the Havoc.
Like the damage.
And then like, they're rewarding headshots more, too.
You know, Apex has always had a thing where like, sometimes the settings revert itself if you don't touch the game in a very long time.
So like, that's me.
So I was just like, oh fuck, okay.
So my settings, when I was like using it, my settings were all different.
I was like, not different, but like, I was like, okay, these are default.
Because I have special settings for certain things.
So I was like, wait a minute, this is default.
Is the Kraber insta-kill?
This shreds so fucking hard.
Auto charge, right?
Yeah.
This is a care package weapon now.
I heard this is really strong, too, but...
Oh my god!
What?!
Okay.
But I'm bad with this.
I'm bad with the single fire.
But like, those who know how to play charge rifle is really good with single fire.
Okay, wait.
210?
It still doesn't insta-kill, unless I missed a headshot.
I could've missed a headshot, not gonna lie.
Yeah, 210?
That's... yeah.
I don't know.
I feel like, cause there's no helmet now.
There's no helmet now, so it still doesn't insta-kill.
I don't think it insta-kills.
Does it?
Yeah.
Oh wait, but then they are wearing red armor.
Oh, that's true, I forgot.
They're wearing red, but there's no red armor anymore.
There's no red armor, I forgot about that.
So yeah, it insta-kills.
By the way, they removed red armor.
They removed red armor, and they also removed helmets, so like, headshots are worth more now.
So, I could do this and be like, haha.
I don't remember how I played with Bochek, but like...
Okay, nevermind.
No haha for me, I guess.
No, haha.
I guess I'll stop aiming for the head.
No haha.
Oh my god, it's been so long since I played with Bochek.
Nevermind.
No hahas.
No.
I don't remember what this is like.
Wait, is it cause I have 3x?
I'm not good with 3x.
Yeah, there we go.
I feel a lot better now.
I'm not good with the 3x.
Yeah, there we go.
Haha, there we go.
That's the old...
I'm better at...
It's actually really fucking weird.
I'm better at the Ironsight for Bochek than I am with the 3x.
Like...
I was like, what was it?
Oh yeah, I forgot.
Haha.
It's like that video where like, oh I forgot I'm white.
It's like, oh I forgot.
I can't aim with 3x.
Haha.
I love that video.
That video is so funny.
I don't know.
It's so out of con...
It's from Boondocks and it's like...
It's so out of context.
But it's just so funny.
Oh, what video?
Oh, it's like...
It's a Boondocks video so like...
You guys can sort of tell what the...
It's like, wait a minute.
I'm white.
Haha.
I'm not white by the way.
But it's like, wait a minute.
I can't aim with 3x.
Haha.
I'm an Ironsight player.
That's such a good out of context video.
Alright, let's get into it.
Okay, guys.
Let's die on repeat until I figure out if I still like this game.
Let's figure out if I still like this game, guys.
Alright, it's been a hot minute since we played Apex Legends.
So...
No, we're not going straight into fucking rank.
Are you crazy?
Like...
We're not going straight into rank, guys.
I'm not that crazy.
Um...
Really interesting.
Like I said, I haven't...
I haven't touched Apex in a hot minute.
So I am incredibly...
Uh...
Incredibly rusty and everything.
So it's gonna be interesting.
I am at the end of the...
Oh, that's cool.
My team is like right there.
To be fair, I don't even know...
I guess that's my SBMM.
What even are the meta legends anyway?
I guess like they got rid of shield meta, right?
Did it get rid of...
Um...
I heard the shield meta...
I mean, it is...
It is pretty...
Pretty much of a dog shit meta.
Um...
I don't know.
Let's try Ashe, I guess.
She can dash now, right?
They changed Ashe...
Uh...
For like her dash abilities, I believe.
So it'll be interesting to see.
Oh, invisible woman!
Pick invisible woman, Doki!
Yeah!
Okay, let's see what...
What are my things?
Gain a phase breach charge.
Our snare is triple and can catch them all.
Gain a phase breach charge?
What the fuck is a phase...
Oh!
Gain a dash charge.
I guess I should try...
What the fuck is phase breach?
I'm just like...
What the fuck are all these...
Turrets!
Oh, great!
My...
No gun.
Cool.
Alright.
Sorry, buddy.
I don't have a gun.
Okay, I can...
I got a gun now.
I'm coming back.
I'm coming back to help them.
Okay, so shift is the dash.
Okay, that's good to know.
Alright, hey guys!
I'm here to help now.
Oh my god!
What the fuck!
Okay, it's jump.
It's jump.
Okay.
You can't bhop.
Okay, I just realized.
Bhopping is bad.
Okay.
Bhopping is...
Oh my god, you can't bhop on her.
You cannot bhop on her.
I just realized that.
If you bhop on her, you use your dash accidentally.
Wait, what?
Oh.
Okay.
Where is she?
Oh shit!
No!
Yeah, so like, the jump is her dash.
Not the third party!
Oh, I live.
I live that.
When you kill someone, they die!
It's okay.
I'm not last.
At least I'm not the last squad.
It feels good to be back.
I forgot about the third party.
Okay, so what I learned is that...
That's...
Oh, I don't know about it.
I don't like that the dash is on the jump.
There's only six other players.
Where's Luna Snow?
Where is she?
Oh my god.
The Apex Iroh.
Where's Mayu?
I know she doesn't read and gets baited.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Goldenhelm.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
These are Doki Bird settings from four years ago.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, let me read the patch notes.
Fuck this.
I'm reading the patch notes.
I...
I was like...
Wait, the dash is on my jump button?
I was not ready for that.
I was like...
Wait a minute.
What is this?
Okay, there's the combat reserve, the stone reload, automatic reloads, weapon muscle flash is better now.
And then...
Why is...
Why am I not in my game yet?
The season just started!
Where's my game?
Okay, now I got it.
I was gonna say...
How has it taken me 80 years to queue up a game?
It just started.
Alright.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Anyway.
Okay, now my average is going...
Slowly going...
I'm slowly becoming an average player.
No, that...
No, that makes sense.
That's justifiable.
The last time I played Apex was the last time I streamed Apex.
So, whenever that was...
Okay, station...
Okay, healing cells now take 2.5 seconds to complete.
Oh!
Wait, healing is faster now too?
Healing is faster now.
I know about the arsenal thing.
They got rid of helmets.
I know about that.
And then...
What is it?
We worked into gold armor upgrade...
Okay, gold helmet improves healing.
POI names.
Knockdown stat.
Significant increased crawl speed while knocked down.
Hand points have been removed.
Okay, there's no...
1x holo has been removed.
They buffed every fucking gun possible.
Every gun is buffed.
Okay, there you go.
I just see like a list of gun choices and it's...
Oh, it's just us two?
Alright, that's cool.
Like, just fuck me, I guess.
Alright, Ashe.
Remove the ability to scan death boxes.
Okay, jump key while in the air to perform a dash.
I hate that.
I hate that it's on my jump key.
Cause that's my...
Cause then it fucks up with my bunny hopping too.
So, I don't like that.
I don't... I never...
I don't like that dash is on the jump.
Just cause like my bunny hop is also on jump.
Cool.
I don't know if I like the names.
I don't know.
It really ruins my immersion when I can see the fuck giant ass names in front of me.
They're like, yeah, but it's help...
I'm not gonna lie.
They're like, it helps the new players.
And I'm like...
They can press...
They can press M.
I don't know.
I just think they can just press M.
That's just my opinion.
Ah, fuck!
Okay.
I hate that.
I hate that my dash is on my jump.
I don't know.
I just think it clutters it up, IMO.
It just looks way too cluttered.
For me.
I don't wanna press M.
Then you deserve the rank you have!
If you can't press M, you deserve the rank you have!
Go!
Go in!
You're raked!
I'm not!
Oh my god.
Trying to make sure...
Do I have Q?
I'm surprised nobody is running at us.
I forgot.
I forgot other teams have, like, three players.
We have one.
Or we have two.
Alright, let's get...
Let's go in.
So mean!
I'm gonna go in and die!
I thought there was a guy here.
What happened to him?
I don't have any more ammos.
I'm gonna press this.
I'm a little scared to go in.
They have three of them.
And then it's just us two.
I feel a little scared, buddy.
Ah!
I hate that jump.
I really do.
I'm not a fan of that.
How many dashes do I have?
Okay, it's a charge.
Okay.
At least now I know.
I'm just not a fan of the...
I'm just not a fan of the dash jump scare.
I don't know.
I feel like dash should not be on jump.
But that's just my opinion.
Oh my god, it's throwing me off so much.
It actually is throwing me off.
Wait, where?
What are you looking at?
Oh.
She's above me.
Gonna drop down?
Oh.
No!
Oh, make sure you die.
If that's the last thing I do.
Oh shit.
Oh, that guy's a cringe player.
Oh my god.
I can tell you're fucking cringe.
I can tell.
I can...
Oh man, now I know how people play.
I know how people play Ashe.
Now I know.
I know how the Ashe players play now.
Now I know what it's for.
I seen like the mini, the micro hops.
And I was like, you know, you deserve that.
You know what?
Yeah.
Fucking...
I hope that micro bunny hop saves your fucking ass.
Oh, it did it?
Oh, wow.
Too bad for you.
Oh my god.
Jesus.
Okay, now I know how Ashe is played.
Oh man.
Wow, it didn't save you?
Who would've fucking thought?
Holy shit.
I just see the Ashe doing like 360 hops and everywhere.
This is the toxic doki I've missed.
It's literally my second game and I had to deal with...
I had to deal with cringe.
Oh my god.
It's so weird because it's like...
The new update definitely makes Apex much more faster paced now.
So you can tell I'm like...
For people who are newer at the game, you guys might not notice it.
Because for you guys, what I do seems really fast.
But for more experienced Apex players, people can notice that I'm playing really slow right now.
Because I'm like trying to remember...
I'm like literally just trying to remember how to play.
I'm like trying to remember what my buttons were.
Because I'm like slowly trying to figure it out.
Yeah.
I know I'm playing slow because I'm like...
What am I trying to...
What guns do I want to play with?
And I'm like...
Where were my buttons again?
You can hear the gears are just turning in my head.
And just like trying to be like...
I have to do this and that.
I know Ashe is very good for movement players.
For sure.
I would agree that Ashe is like...
I don't know if I like the names thing.
Because like...
It just feels so cluttered for me.
Yeah, they brought back tap strafing.
All the people were complaining about the tap strafing thing.
And then like...
And then they brought it back because like...
They were worried that the game was going to die even more.
I think competitively, Apex is fine.
But like...
Like...
Apex cannot be propped up by just competitive play.
I just think like...
Competitively, the game is fine.
But like...
Hub-wise, it's not.
But for the casual player base, it is absolutely not okay.
Woah.
Please leave me alone.
I'm just a little guy.
Nice.
Jesus Christ.
I forgot I was Wraith there.
I forgot I was Wraith.
I was just like...
Why is my Q not working?
I was trying to Q the door.
Okay, let me...
She'll...
She'll sell healing so fast now.
I hope my guy is okay.
But I don't think he is.
You're fine, right?
Oh!
No!
Don't hold your shield up!
What do you mean?!
You don't even...
It's one button!
It's one button, Irishman!
You can't even hold your shield up!
Bro!
It's one fucking button!
I feel that.
Legitimately!
All you had to do!
Oh, that's the turkey we love.
I'm just saying he couldn't even...
I literally...
My entire plan was to use him as cover and he couldn't even give me that.
He couldn't even give me my cover.
I have to...
Jesus Christ.
Legitimately!
One button!
And then I would've been okay.
Oh my God.
His button can't be broken!
Cause you know what that button is?
It's the shooting button!
You can't say his button was broken!
It's literally the button to shoot your gun!
You think I don't know that?
Jesus Christ.
Okay, is that the arsenal?
Okay, I'm gonna keep the Prowler I guess.
How do I do this?
Oh, to enhance power?
Oh shit, did I enhance it?
Did I do it?
Nice.
Cool.
Okay, and then you can get Hemlock.
I'm gonna keep the...
Should I keep the Prowler or the Flatline?
I don't know.
Let's see.
Did you see him shoot?
Yeah, he got someone down!
I saw that guy!
I don't know if I wanna do Prowler.
I think you just like click on it.
That's really it.
There's really nothing else.
I want an R9!
Where's my R9?
Is there no R9s anywhere?
The fuck is this?
It came out of the fucking thing and there's no R9?
Where's my fucking R9?
That's my entire life mission!
Fuck it.
Oh, we'll just grab that.
Have we tried a new charge rifle?
I fucking hate charge rifle.
I hate the charge up for it.
At least we got the...
Yeah, with no attachments though.
There's so...
Wait, the icons are different now too.
I just noticed that.
There's like...
I guess those are arsenal icons.
I'm pretty sure.
Oh, this guy wants to fight.
Where's my beloved R9?
That's the whole reason why I was so happy to try out the new changes.
That's the only reason.
I just want the R9.
Oh, that's awkward.
Oh, that's awkward, buddy.
That's so awkward.
Wait, where's my...
Where's the res beacon anyway?
Let's see.
I know I'm trying to figure out where to reboot.
There's no reboot over there.
So I'm gonna go...
I'm gonna go over here to reboot.
Let's see.
I wanna fight team there.
Okay.
Alright.
He wants to fight the team here.
Okay.
Oh.
Well, guess we're not fighting this team here.
Okay.
I was like, alright, I'll do that.
I guess I won't do that then.
I'll reboot him in the storm.
Fuck it.
Alright.
They're gonna chase us, so you get out your fight regardless.
And I grab this too.
Alright.
So about that fight you wanted.
So about that fight.
They're here.
There you go.
Wait, what?
How's there more people?
He like knocked somebody.
Do I have enough heals?
I do.
Okay.
I'm trying to see where they are.
Jesus Christ.
He's one.
Alright.
Oh, he left.
Okay.
Hey, at least he got his fight.
Right?
That's what he wanted.
I'm just gonna grab some fucking heal- I need this 3x, Jesus Christ.
Alright.
I'm picking you up, buddy.
I'm picking you up again.
Alright.
Let's- Do I have enough heals for this though?
That's the thing.
I don't know if I have enough heals.
Oh wait, there's more heals here.
Okay, I do.
Alright, I guess- Let me grab some heals real fast.
Ooh!
Nice.
Yummy.
I'll take these.
Ooh, yummy.
Oh my gosh, so yummy.
Oh!
Oh my god, it's my birthday!
Alright, let's see.
18 syringes.
I'll go pick him up right now here.
I'll go Res him right here.
It's 18 syringes, so like, that's fine.
Oh wait, there's more.
More yummy.
Okay, I can Res him in a minute.
I'll be fine.
Holy shit, there's so much yummy.
Happy birthday to me!
Can I get this in time?
Yeah, I can.
I'll be fine.
I have a portal too.
I feel like this is just my job.
Alright, here we go.
My new job.
Alright.
Here we go.
Off I go.
I'm literally just a transporter.
I'm just here to transport bodies.
Alright.
I'm not gonna... yeah, I'm...
I'm on the medic meta.
Why are we here?
Why here?
Why do we go...
Why are we going the long way to get the zone?
Our poor guy's gonna fucking die now!
Oh my...
I'm fucking...
I'm walking.
Fuck this.
Oh hey, there's a care package.
Where are we going?
I guess he wanted...
Is that an R9?
Oh my god, that's an R9.
Yummy.
I'm gonna grab this R9.
Okay.
What's this?
30-30.
Ooh, Havoc.
Ooh, yummy.
Reduce tactical lineup.
I'm a little worried right now.
Oh no, there's a team in front of me.
I'm very worried.
Are we...
Oh, we have two ideas of where we wanna go.
Okay.
Where is he going?
Is he going into that zone?
Or is he going to me?
Where is he going?
Where does he wanna go?
Oh, this way.
Okay.
I'm just like...
Where do you wanna go, buddy?
It's hard to tell.
It's so fucking hard to tell where he wants to go.
Alright.
Oh, there's fights to my right.
Why did we go that way?
Why the fuck did we go...
Oh my god, I don't understand.
Our random's doing really well, so like...
Whatever.
Oh, somebody fell?
Wait, it says...
I don't know if they're real.
He's going that way.
But where is he going?
Bro, what the fuck?
Why didn't we just fight that guy...
That team over to...
Are we playing zone?
There's no fucking way he's playing zone.
There's no way.
Oh my god.
Oh, thank god.
I was gonna be like...
I swear to god, if you're playing zone...
After everything we've been through...
I swear to fucking god.
Okay.
Oh, we are playing zone.
Where is he shooting?
Wait, what?
Oh my god, there's the other...
Oh, where did he go?
Yeah, buddy.
How did our guy die?
The fuck is a Hornet?
Should I get the Hornet?
What the fuck?
Woah!
What do I have in my arms right now?
Okay, sorry.
I needed to grab the Hornet.
I was so confused what that was.
What the fuck is this tentacle fucker in my arm?
Okay, I'll go...
Alright.
Back at it again.
Woah!
It's time to play the medic.
Yippee!
I love being a medic on my team.
Let's go.
Oh, shit.
Sorry.
Give me a sec.
This is much more important.
Oh, it's...
Wait, is this...
The fuck are all these names?
The Hornet?
The Vine?
Whatever.
The Lime?
The fuck are these names?
I hope he doesn't show up.
That's fine.
No!
That's not fine!
I risked my life for you, mad Irishman!
Please!
I risked my entire life for you, mad Irishman!
I literally facetanked that shit!
I swear to God!
If I die after everything I've been through...
I swear to God.
The medic down.
Do I get to play a real game yet?
Do I...
I'm not phoenixkidding.
I don't trust any of them.
Like, can I shoot my gun, please?
Why?
Can I...
Can I please just shoot my gun?
Is that too much to ask for?
But, like, what is this?
Is that a R-301?
You will then point to DPS forces somewhere.
Like, what is my...
What is this?
Like, what in my gun am I holding?
I'm just gonna go straight in.
It's just one guy.
Wait, another squad?
Jesus Christ, I need to take some cover right now.
Okay.
Where's the other team?
I need a bat, though.
Oh, no.
This is bad.
We are no zone.
Hey, this is where we die, right?
This is...
Oh, my God.
We should not have pushed down.
We should...
I don't know why we pushed down there.
Why the fuck there was a...
We came up high ground like that.
Oh, my God.
I just...
I just wanted...
I felt like a...
I felt like I was playing support in a DPS game.
I...
I felt like I was just playing support.
I couldn't even use my R-9.
Everybody was just too far for it.
Whose idea was that?
Not mine.
I saw someone else went down first.
Okay.
What the fuck are these guns I had in my hand?
I need...
Like, I was looking through the...
All right.
Where is it?
What is this?
In collaboration.
Okay.
Where are these guns even called?
It doesn't even say.
Okay.
Let's see.
Where is it?
Wait.
Is she live?
I've been waiting to send this for weeks.
Me.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
301 with mythic skin buffs.
Okay.
I'm finding where the...
I don't see it.
I was like, what is that my holding at?
What am I holding?
Okay.
There's three.
Hornet.
Faster movement and reload speed.
Attack charge on shield break.
Alt charge on knock.
Oh shit.
Wait.
Hornet sounds like the...
Oh, it helps relent.
Oh, wait.
Limelight.
Helps replenish your squad's health and shields.
The fuck?
That is so...
Okay.
And triggers thermite.
I had...
What did I have?
I didn't even know what I...
What gun I was holding.
Was I holding a Hornet?
I think I was holding a Hornet.
Okay.
With faster movement and reload speed.
The attack charge on shield break.
And alt charge on knock.
Okay.
So Limelight seems to be the best one out of all of them.
Alright.
Then I guess I'll try out the Limelight.
I feel like Limelight seems like the best one because of the heal.
It can heal people on damage.
How's your memory this bad?
It's not bad.
I literally just deleted it.
I was like, this information is not important enough, Dali.
So, Lopez, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Also, I can't read, too.
So there's that...
Who am I waiting for?
The three people that hasn't loaded in.
You can...
Yeah, I just like...
In my head, I'd be like, not important.
And then I just throw it in the trash.
And it happens instantaneously.
Okay.
Now that I know what...
I don't know if I like Ashe.
I don't think I like the...
I don't like that jump.
I'll try it.
I don't like that jump is...
Dash.
Because usually dash is for...
Usually you don't put dash on the jump button.
Because it fucks up the...
It fucks up bunny hopping.
So unless I have to...
I guess I have to re...
Like, I have to unbind my scroll wheel and stuff for it.
Because I don't know.
I don't really like that jump is dash.
It's just harder to like...
It's harder to like...
Figure it out.
Because I...
I'm...
Because I always...
I always scroll wheel.
I always use scroll wheel.
For dash.
For jumping.
Because that's what you do for consistent...
For consistent bunny hopping.
And...
Wall...
Like, wall jumping and stuff too.
What's the new...
Wait, what do they do for ballistic?
I'll try ballistic next.
I'll try ballistic.
Alright, we'll go here.
Okay.
Yeah, usually they put it on shift or something.
So that's why...
It just throws me off so much.
That they put it...
Oh my gosh, of course I get...
Because like, I do this.
But then, like, that's my...
But I would bunny hop a lot.
But like...
You can't...
I can't do that.
I can't.
Because that's where my dash is.
I'll grab this actually.
I'll just go double energy for now.
Anybody here?
I don't know if anybody's here.
Yeah, and then you can't wall, but that's so true.
Um...
Yeah, see?
Like, I used my dash there when I was just trying to wall bounce too.
I like the idea, but the execution is pretty bad.
I'm like...
I don't know.
The execution for it is pretty bad.
Not gonna lie.
It just...
Yeah.
The idea is good.
I appreciate the cool idea.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I'm coming over.
Don't worry, Turbo!
I have no idea where they are, but I'll throw this out there.
Oh.
They loba-queued though.
That's a cool idea.
Let's see.
Alright.
Oh, she dashed too.
There we go.
Where's the...
Where's your teammate?
Is he running away?
You know what that means!
Wait, where did he go?
Wait, where did he crawl to?
I was like...
Oh, he crawled there.
Okay.
I was like, where the fuck?
He just disappeared.
I was gonna...
Oh my god!
I just wanted to scroll.
I was gonna do a finisher on him.
I was like...
He disappeared.
He crawled away.
He crawled so fast!
He like, buffed the crawl speed so he was gone!
I was ready to do a finisher on him.
Why is...
Why is Iwotoki French?
The French know why.
You know why.
You don't even have to be French to know why.
I'm gonna grab the arsenal.
My arsenal.
Not arsenal.
Whatever this was called.
Extra supplies bin.
Alright.
Let's see.
Wait, there's the energy.
Oh wait, there's the energy one!
Wait, that's good.
I need that actually.
I need to power up.
Nice.
Did it happen?
Did it work?
Oh, it enhanced my mag.
Okay.
Okay, it enhanced my mag.
Alright, get in here.
Thunder boy!
Get...
Thunder boy, get in here!
Thunder boy, do you know how to play video games?!
Sorry.
Okay.
Okay, it's fine.
Everything is fine.
I'm okay.
I'm not toxic.
Everything is fine.
I was just...
You know, it was just a simple question.
He's just a little boy!
He's gonna be a man today!
How do I word that laugh request in my voice packed French laugh?
Yeah, that's really it.
It's just playful guys.
It was just playful banter.
I asked very calmly.
I'm just trying to help him become a man, guys.
It's just that.
A lot of people fucking died here.
Holy shit.
Oh my god, look at all.
Died a hundred.
Jesus Christ.
An army died here.
I guess you can still get these.
Am I ever gonna find an R9?
Like, naturally?
Oh, I am.
Nice.
I asked and I received.
I don't know why.
Should I gain a phase breach charge or an arc?
I feel like I should get another charge.
For that.
You have to stop seeing things like that.
Alright.
Things will not.
I don't think things will be okay.
Eight squads left.
Holy.
This game is so much faster now.
The fact that it's eight squads left.
And like, there's still like a million.
Like, it's still.
Is this still zone one?
Yeah, this is still zone one.
Oh my god.
It's literally zone one and only eight squads left.
That's crazy.
Alright.
This is where I die.
Because I don't remember how this map goes.
Where is the exit?
Okay, there's the exit.
I could not.
I cannot remember how to get out of here.
They have to be in front of me.
Yeah, they are.
Okay.
That was a little bit stupid on his part.
What the fuck?
I got deleted so fast.
Jesus.
Yeah.
I need to do this so I can heal.
Jesus Christ.
Alright, give me a sec while I heal.
That was so fast.
I was not expecting how fast that was.
That was actually such a fast fucking hit.
I was like, I literally looked at.
I felt like I looked at him for one second and it was over for me.
Oh.
I don't have like anything for this.
I don't even know if this is smart.
This was definitely not smart.
Thank God.
Wait, what?
There's somebody here.
There you go.
No, no!
I got it!
I fucking got it!
I had the third party!
I just realized that there was a third party.
Oh no.
That's why I'm gonna follow you.
Oh my God, I'm so fast.
So fast.
That's right, I still win that 1v1 though.
Oh shit, I take that.
And you had a gold and you still lost that 1v1?
That's crazy.
No!
Oh my God!
I thought I risked it.
Oh my God, but I crossed so fast.
Oh my God.
No!
I thought I risked it.
I was like, they won't know.
How would they know?
I was like, how would they know?
And they knew.
They fucking knew.
I couldn't believe it.
I was like, there's no way.
There's no way they would know.
But they knew.
I didn't even shoot the gold!
I didn't even shoot the gold gun.
But I did kill the Octane when he had a gold gun and I had a non-attachment R9.
I should've ulted away.
I was like, I was so cocky there.
I was like, they won't know.
How would they know?
I was like, let me just heal here in this corner.
As they slowly approached me.
There's no way they would know.
There's no way.
I was greedy.
I admit.
I was so confident.
I was incredible.
Okay, ballistic, right?
Where's ballistic?
Where is he?
Is that ballistic?
No, that's Fuse.
Fuck!
Sorry!
They're both...
I just see two old men.
And they were the same.
I had Doki.
I saw two old men.
And I was like, that's ballistic, right?
I was like, wait, no.
He's not old enough.
They both had beards.
So I went with the...
I went with the wrong beard.
I went with the wrong...
Not all old men are the same.
I'm sorry!
I clearly saw a beard.
And then when I clicked on him, I was like, wait a minute.
His beard's supposed to be white, isn't it?
Okay, it's like facial hair.
I was like, okay, they both have facial hair.
Clearly, I fucked...
Okay, I fucked up.
I fucked up.
Not all men...
Not all old men are the same.
I now know that, guys.
I've learned.
Not all old men are the same old men.
You guys know Fuse is married to Bloodhound now?
They like got married and everything.
That's so cool.
I didn't realize that they can...
I didn't realize that they can actually find happiness in this world.
It's not fair.
Fuse and Bloodhound get somebody.
Yeah, you guys didn't know that?
They got married during...
They got married during ALGS, guys.
Yeah.
Look at that.
If they can find happiness, why can't I?
I'm sorry.
This game has lore, I know, right?
Damn, Doki.
Out of nowhere?
Sorry.
Oh no, I never play Fuse.
I heard someone to my left.
I'm like...
Okay, I just want to make sure.
It ain't so.
What the fuck is wrong with this guy?
What the fuck?
Okay.
This is two teams, by the way.
Like, what was your plan?
Repeating?
This is how they repeat it?
I literally...
Oh my god, I held the fort down and they left.
I literally held the fort down and they left me.
Like, oh my...
But look how fast I crawl.
Oh, and then they rez.
And then they fucking rez.
How am I washed?
This is a team game.
I literally...
I literally held the fort down.
I was like...
Like, their Bangalore was so fucking stupid.
I'm literally...
Oh, okay.
Yeah, no.
I wasn't going to win that fight.
How is there still people 3-stacking pubs?
Oh, well, I guess this is the only way to find joy.
No, I get it.
No, no, no.
It's understandable.
It's the only way to find joy right now.
It's the...
I was going to win that fight.
Oh my god.
I was like...
Excuse me?
You all left me to die?
The laughter sounds like crying on the inside.
Guys, I just need one win.
Guys, I just...
Oh my god.
I'm literally at the end of the stage.
The spectrum.
I swear to god in my...
I'm at the end of the spectrum.
My mommy says I'm special.
Okay, get the right...
Don't worry.
I'll get the right old man this time.
There, see?
I got the right one.
I got the right old man now.
Yes, Happy.
This is the right old man.
We know.
Mommy says it's a gift.
How am I always jump master?
I don't want to be jump master.
I'm tired of being jump master.
I want to go ape shit.
How are we at the end of the spectrum?
Oh no, I'm fucking...
I'm degrading my SPM.
Good.
You know what?
No, I deserve it.
I...
How am I at the end of the spectrum?
Oh, Doki.
You don't want to ask questions you won't...
You don't want the answers to.
Please tell me there's a gun here.
Nice.
Okay.
How do I play this game again?
I have a Q.
What the fuck?
He just opened the door like that?
Hey, me too.
Okay.
There's a climb up here.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god, he has a shotgun.
Where am I?
Wait, that's a different person that went down for me.
That's...
What?
He has two shot...
Mom gave you two shotguns?
I was like, wait a minute.
That's a different person.
Like, I was like...
I thought I shot an old man.
Yeah, I was like, wait a minute.
How did my old man became a woman?
I was so surprised.
That fast?
I was like, wait.
That's...
Wait, I'm so confused.
I was like,
your HP is so high too.
I was like, that fast?
I'm sorry.
What a name.
Okay, wait.
Oh, he's a roller player.
Oh, that's embarrassing.
That's embarrassing.
I don't know if she can...
You don't have to...
Oh my god, okay.
Alright, let's...
Oh, it's cause they got the fucking arsenal.
That's how.
I was gonna be like, how the fuck does he have two shotguns?
I...
I was so...
I was so confused.
You get...
You get a red beacon when you pick up a banner.
You get a...
Okay, I don't think he knows.
He did not look in the box.
Apparently, I don't...
I never tried it before.
But you get a red beacon...
As you guys didn't know.
You get a red beacon when you pick up a banner.
Alright.
Oh my god.
I was so...
I was just like...
Guys, we can win this.
I can remember how to play this game again.
I can.
What's the point of map res if you don't pick up the...
If you don't pick up the fucking...
I guess if you don't pick up the res beacon.
Alright, let's grab something in our lives.
Let's start missing some shots.
Let's...
Let's embarrass ourselves even more.
Let's just...
You know, fuck yeah.
I feel like...
I've already get rock bottom.
What's the worst that can happen?
Yeah.
Let's just embarrass ourselves just a little bit more.
Alright, let's see.
There's people here.
So I'm a little bit scared.
Hello?
Alright.
Oh no.
That's just a...
That's just a wall.
Nevermind.
I was like, there he is!
And then I just like...
No, that's just a...
That's just a little stick on the air.
I mean, the R9 does feel nice.
I feel like I'm winning fights with...
Okay, increase ult.
Whistler duration in the world is triple.
Increase ult duration...
Eh.
I'll do the ult duration if I can live that long.
I feel like...
I feel like my...
The R9 is good.
That way?
Oh shit.
Wait, they're so far.
I didn't even realize they ran so far.
If I can get an R9, it'll be over.
I'm heading over.
Guys, give me a sec, guys.
I didn't realize you guys ran.
It's okay.
If they die, then like, I can...
Then like, I can rez them.
Guys, I'm so far away, guys.
Let's hope they don't die by the time I get there.
Because I actually want to be part of this fight.
Oh okay, it's looking less and less likely.
I just realized I have my ult for a fucking wingman.
Might not be the smartest choice.
Like, where are they?
Where are they fighting?
Oh, right here.
Okay.
Oh, I thought I could climb...
Oh fuck!
Yeah, I'm backing out.
Okay, I need a scope for this wingman.
I realize I don't know how to shoot without a scope.
Oh my god, I don't know the distance for climbing anymore.
It's been so long.
Aim, like I said.
Are you serious?
Guys, guys, guys!
Really?!
Oh my god, what?!
That guy actually left me?!
Oh my god!
They actually left!
I was like, oh clearly they're gonna come back, right?
They heard the gunshot, right?
And they all just ran off!
What the...
Oh my god!
We're a team, right?!
They just...
Guys, I'm not playing ballistic.
I need like an actual escape.
It's just as rough as I remember.
I thought they'll turn around!
I thought they'd actually turn around!
They heard the gunshot!
So I was just like, they'll turn around, right?
Oh my god.
I was not expecting...
I was like, okay, I can't run in the open.
Cause like, there's no cover and there's an entire team next to me.
So, I'll stay here.
And then my teammates, you know, in my head, I was like...
My teammates, they'll get an off angle.
Because they're perfectly positioned to get an off angle for this.
And then, so they can't push me for free.
Because they're over there.
Silly me for thinking that far ahead.
God, that's so silly of me.
That really is.
So fucking silly.
I forgot people don't do that.
In a pub.
That's so silly.
Oh, but he's a pro fucking runner at least.
You know, at least he's a pro dodger.
Wow!
Oh my god.
Alright, I'm not playing ballistic.
I actually need to play a character that can run away.
I'm not...
I've played a team game for so long.
Guys, I've played team games for so long.
I actually forgot what it's like to be a solo player.
Because in Rivals, even if you're a solo queue player in Rivals.
You can depend on your teammates.
Because it's a team game.
Um...
So, so I gotta readjust my thinking here.
To remember that, that ain't true no more.
That ain't, that's not true.
But it truly was.
I, I never learned how to be a fucking, a fucking solo queue player.
In, in a Battle Royale.
I cannot play a team game in that fact.
Oh my god.
Okay, let's see.
I guess like, Wraith is the best solo queue.
I don't know if Bangalore is still good.
So I'll just play Wraith for the queue.
God, I remember how to...
Yeah, I forgot.
You gotta be incredibly selfish when you're playing, when you're playing fucking Apex Legends.
I forgot about that, guys.
Ugh.
Okay, this time it'll be different, right?
This time.
Vantage is fun?
Yeah, but I don't have a team.
Vantage is fun when you have a team so you don't get walked up on.
Battle Royale was making me so soft.
No, it did.
It made me feel like I have people I can rely on.
But then I forgot the world is a cruel place.
I can't believe I thought, like, I can rely on people and that people are not stupid as fuck.
I forgot about that.
This is the real world.
Rivalous is like...
Marvel Rivalous is like the dream you had where you're like, what it was like to have world peace and everything and people working together.
And then...
I bet some of you guys were like, well, not in my games, but like in my games.
In the higher elo games.
And then Apex is like the real world.
The world today where everything is on fire.
Wake up!
This is the actual world.
We all woke up and this is the real world that we have to live in.
Wake up, Samurai.
The world's on fire.
You're living it.
Okay, I'm not playing for the team anymore.
No, never again.
I'll still stay with the team.
I wanna get that bin to the right.
Or left.
Okay, there's people fighting here.
I hear people in front of me.
Jesus Christ, I hear a lot of people in front of me.
I mean, I could...
Double check this.
Do something dumb.
Oh my god, that was so dumb.
That was actually so dumb.
Oh hey, he's a roller player.
Okay.
Should reload for me, right?
I holstered it.
Didn't it say it should reload?
Shouldn't it?
Do I have a holster?
I don't know.
I'm not reading things properly as always.
Oh, I got the standard stock.
Brave and dumb.
That's right.
I need to be aware of what the TTK is now.
Damn.
You okay, buddy?
Oh, it's assault classes only.
Okay.
That's good to know.
I don't know which is an assault class, but that's...
I don't know which one, but that's good to know.
Where's my ping?
481?
Okay.
Alright.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, there's a Wraith to my right.
Wait, what?
Oh shit, that's our guy.
I thought it was the fucking enemy team flanking me.
I need to grab ammo.
Don't get rid of this.
What?
Why?
Oh my god, that was so fast.
Just crawl.
That's so fast.
Where?
Jesus Christ.
What the fuck?
I'm dead.
I'm so dead.
No!
I was like, oh yeah, that makes sense that my team was 9.
I did shit on that guy though.
I did shit on him.
I take those.
I shit on that guy.
Couldn't 1v3!
Washed!
She would've been able to 1v3 if she wasn't washed.
Okay.
Okay, with the TTK like that?
Oh my god, I might as well be rank 1.
Oh my god.
Couldn't 1v3.
The Doki I knew would be able to do it.
Oh my god.
Yeah, fuck you!
What does it say about this guy?
He couldn't 1v1!
He couldn't even fucking 1v1!
What does that say about him?
He lost a 1v1 two times in a row!
If I'm washed, what does it say about that?
He is not Doki though.
He was never good to begin with, so not washed.
Okay.
Alright.
Wraith tab.
He's double washed, that's what it says.
We can win a game.
I think we can win a game.
We just gotta play like a little fucking bitch.
Like, play like a little bitch.
Or like, we got, oh my god, everybody's stacking.
It's crazy.
I thought like, I thought they fixed the pub system where...
They're stackers.
That sucks.
I legit thought they fixed the pub system for that.
I feel like, at this point, like, a lot of people are just stacking now.
That's for rank?
No, they do that for pubs too.
It's not just a rank thing, it's a...
Go here.
I wanna... No!
Go here!
Please!
I want the R9!
I'm going there.
I need that R9 right now.
Okay, then I'll upgrade my thing.
Does it do it if I... Oh, it does.
It does give it to me.
Nice.
I'm going for the R9.
I'm surprised nobody landed here.
This has literally the best arsenal.
Which is the R9.
Which is funny because this house has an R9 too.
R9 secured.
Like, so many people fighting over here.
I don't know if we should fight for it though.
Let's just poke.
I think we can win our game.
We might be washed, but like...
It can't be that bad.
Why are they fighting?
I'm trying to figure out where this fight is.
The fuck is this?
Oh, it's over here.
Okay, we can go behind them.
We can actually fight behind them.
Just go.
Give them back shots.
Oh shit!
We got one of them.
That's fine.
Okay.
Where is he?
Oh shit.
Oh, this guy's crazy.
Oh my god, this guy's crazy crazy.
Oh my god, you're fucking crazy crazy.
Okay.
I have one more.
Fuck it!
Nevermind.
Oh, I don't have...
Oh shit!
He pushed him.
Okay, maybe we shouldn't have done back shots.
I don't know now.
That's fine.
It's not, but like...
Oh shit!
Okay, I would...
That was...
That was good.
That was a good play.
Okay.
I would admit...
That play was...
Okay.
Yeah, we weren't winning that.
We weren't winning that.
That was like...
That was a movement play right there.
I would admit...
That's the new ass play.
I will...
I will give him credit.
That was a sick play.
Holy shit.
I was just like...
Okay, so that's how you play Ashe.
I see now.
I think I can do that.
That seems easy to do.
Alright.
You know what?
I'm gonna do duos.
This is...
Trios is too sweaty.
Trios is three sweaty people stacked together.
At least duos...
I could just have to...
At least duos is like two people stacked...
Two sweaty people stacked together.
No, duos is like two sweaty people stacked together.
Trios, apparently, is three fucking people stacked together.
So...
So I'll take what I can get.
If I have five...
Unless duos is dead.
Is duos dead?
Oh, don't tell me duos is dead.
The season just came out.
The...
The season...
The season just came out.
Why is there only 15 people here?
Oh, 17.
I need...
How many people do I need for duos?
How many people have to exist for me to play duos?
Oh my...
Guys...
Oh, 21.
It's going up there.
People are slowly dying.
I can't believe there's only one lobby going on.
That's crazy.
Actually, just one lobby for duos?
I'm gonna make my waiting room for my members stream while we wait.
Like...
I did...
I did do my tweet for my members...
For my members stream.
And we're gonna be here.
Okay, let's see.
Where's my template for my...
For my mem...
Oh my god.
26.
I'll wait it out.
I'll do one game of duos.
And then I'll die instantly.
And then I'll be like, THIS WASN'T WORTH IT!
I have a feeling that that's where it's gonna go, guys.
I don't know.
I have a feeling that we're gonna die on RIP.
And then I'm gonna scream at how that wasn't worth it.
And then I'm gonna go back to trios.
And I'm gonna like...
I'm gonna like...
Actually, I'm gonna go to rank.
I'm gonna...
I didn't win one...
Oh my god.
I don't know if pubs are always this incredibly fucking sweaty.
Or like, I just haven't played in a long ass...
I think it's the lower TTK.
I think it's the lower TTK too.
The lower TTK has made it seem even harder.
Just cause like...
Because like, people just die so much faster.
This is how I remember pubs.
Pubs has always been this sweaty.
It's been so long since I played pubs.
Like, I forgot it was like this.
I've been in like...
I've been happy for so long.
I forgot what it was like.
That like...
And the insta queues too.
I think that's the worst.
The fact that it isn't insta queue has to make me like...
What was the word?
Like, just like think about what just happened.
What's that word?
Where you're like, retrospect.
Like, I have to be...
I have to actually like let everything sink in and be more aware of what just happened.
And yeah, I have to do self reflection.
There's too much time to self reflect.
I missed it when it was insta queue.
So I don't have to think about my actions.
Instead, I'm sitting here.
I'm stuck here.
I have to wait.
Oh my god.
Alright, let's see.
Did I make my members?
I did.
I already made my members waiting room.
Alright, let's see.
I'm gonna put that here.
And then...
It's the free...
The queue is so long.
I'm fucking making my waiting room tweet for my next stream.
It's the free to play Fall Guys game where they made a skin for Mr. Beast.
Alright, let's see.
I have to ponder all my misplays exactly.
And the silence too.
Oh, the game sound started.
Wait, why am I not in?
Wait.
Wait, guys.
Guys.
No, I waited so long.
Wait.
Excuse me?
No, they can't do this to me.
Oh, thank god.
That's gonna be like...
Can't do this to me.
The fact that I have to listen to that.
I think I can do what that Ashe did to me.
I just need to remember not to bunny hop.
That's all I need to do.
As long as I don't bunny hop, it should be okay, right?
I thought he was gonna kick me out after everything I did.
The good, good Ashe boy.
I don't think this guy knows how to spell.
Okay.
If we go to the core, we can get an R and I.
Okay, let's just die.
You waited the same amount of time as I waited for a queue.
Like, no, maybe even more.
Like, you're gonna throw away your life just like that.
Just like that, you're gonna throw away your life.
We waited for that queue for so long!
And you're just gonna throw it all away!
Also, Dipper, thank you, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Where the fuck is the light ammo arsenal?
Oh my god, I swear to god.
If I land here and then, like, I die, I swear to fucking god.
Okay.
Where's my- where's my buddy?
Oh, there he is.
I'm a little scared, guys, not gonna lie.
I don't know if I can, uh, I don't know if I can trust Troy from High School Musical.
Do you trust Troy from High School Musical?
Cause I don't.
Hey, Troy.
Troy!
Okay.
Is he gonna push up?
He's gonna run?
Okay, that's interesting.
He's just running off like that.
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
I won my one.
Are you gonna win your one?
He's not.
He did not win his- he didn't win his one, guys.
I was just like, I don't think he's gonna win his one.
I carry Troy, I'm the Gabriella to his Troy.
They're like over here.
I'm pretty sure.
That's where the- that's where the Lobo is, yeah.
Oh, he does not- he is so lost.
He does not know how to read Lobo cues.
In what world do you think they're on the other side?
They're obviously up here.
Oh, Troy.
Troy, Troy, Troy.
I'm gonna get an off-angle.
Where's my teammate?
Oh, there he is.
Wait, you're supposed to not be here.
I'm getting the off-angle.
Troy!
Oh my God, Troy, now they're here!
Troy, you fucker!
This is why you get an off-angle!
Oh my God, Troy!
Okay, alright.
I don't like Troy.
Oh no!
My Troy!
My Troy had a rough time, man!
He fucking got cued!
He had five seconds to process that cue, but he still stayed there.
He still stayed- I'll do one more.
I'll do one more duo.
And then I'll go to rank.
Maybe rank would be less sweaty.
Dead God, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Hey, Doug, you lost my account with a one-year badge to a glitch.
Should I start a new one?
When YouTube randomly gave me the OG account back!
Should I continue my glitched account's one-year badge or restart on my non-buster account?
Why not both?
I think you have two chonky goons.
Less sweaty?
You see, my rank is bronze, so it'd definitely be less sweaty.
You chill in rank and try hard on quick play.
That seems about it!
That seems how it goes now.
It's a free-to-play where they made Mr. Beast a skin for Mr. Beast.
I'm ready to destroy my dragoon.
Is this the right waiting room?
I think it is.
Let me double check.
I swear to God, if bronze is just as sweaty, I swear to fucking God, I'm going to find something and be like...
Oh my God.
Dragoon's Destroyer.
Okay, I believe in Alejandro Ventos 3.
I believe in a guy that doxes himself in Apex Legends.
That's already a good sign.
If he is willing to dox himself in Apex Legends, he has zero fear.
He has zero fucking fear.
That's dedication right there.
I believe.
That's a man with nothing to lose.
Exactly.
Exactly, guys.
Alright, Alejandro.
You have nothing to lose.
And I have everything to lose.
And then he's playing Loba in duos.
Okay.
Okay, I believe.
Even though I see he's on Loba in duos, I fucking believe.
My belief hasn't wavered yet.
When do I get my, like, master duo player that still plays this game regularly?
Like, when do I get that?
Like, I don't ask for much.
Just for someone to carry me.
Like, is that too much to ask for?
Are there good players that still play this game?
That solo?
That, sorry, I gotta be more specific.
That solo queues?
Are there still good players that still solo queue?
Are they all stacking now?
Or is that what it's led to?
Yes, you.
You're the last solo queue player alive, apparently.
Where are you dropping to, Alejandro?
Like, we don't even make this!
Oh my god!
A very bold move.
Yeah, no, no, no shit.
It's fatal.
No shit.
A bold move.
Yeah.
No, no, he's right.
He's right.
He cooked a little too hard.
Alright.
I don't feel like it's superior positioning right now.
Oh my god.
Okay.
He's so lucky no one landed at the bottom.
He's so fucking lucky.
Alright, I saw the way he did the drop and I knew it was over.
I knew that I'm the better player in this duo.
You still believe?
No, I stopped believing.
No.
Is it obvious that I stopped believing?
Maybe there is hope in this cruel world.
The moment I saw that we were not making it, like, that belief was gone.
And he's not healing, by the way.
I'm not even gonna give him medkits at this point.
I'm not even gonna give him any heals.
Oh my god, he just left you to die like that.
That's fucked up.
Oh, you cross so fast.
Jesus Christ, there's so much loot.
I know this is- Oh hey, R9.
That's what I wanted.
I'm gonna cap your fucking box.
Are you
serious?
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
I hope you're crawling.
Oh, he left.
That's cool.
Alejandro!
Okay.
Okay, Alejandro.
He fucking left.
Alright.
Okay.
Oh, by myself.
That's fine.
I'm not okay.
He ran away.
I can't believe he ran away.
Toki, does this sound like a person that's okay right now?
He's crawling.
Alright, you know what?
I might as well just die, I guess.
Oh my god.
How do I- How do I- Okay.
Alright, now I have to figure out a 1v2 again.
Okay, I can third party that, right?
Where's this fight?
I'm gonna go in prematurely.
Okay, if I go from behind, I don't think they'll hear.
They're like right in front of me.
Okay, I went in prematurely.
I went in prematurely, guys.
They like turned around.
I was not expecting that.
I was not expecting them to turn around.
Jesus Christ.
I was like, what?
Weren't you guys fighting somebody?
Doesn't help that I'm on like white armor.
Yeah, two seconds ago.
And then they went back to kill him!
I'm gonna try and get an armor upgrade.
This white armor is actually killing me right now.
I need to get at least blue armor if I want to make this work.
And if I don't, I just die.
White armor right now as a solo, it fucking hurts.
I think there's people in front of me.
So I don't know.
I saw a gunshot up here.
Alright, this is where I either die or I get away with the biggest heist possible.
Okay, and I'll grab... I'll grab this.
And I'll grab an arsenal too.
UGH!
DAH!
WHY?!
Oh shit, that was a reflex.
What did I get shot by?
Wait, what?
What shot me?
Wait, what shot me?
Here.
What the fuck?!
These little fucking rats!
Fucking hell, you guys are such rats.
Oh my god.
Jesus.
Actual fucking rats.
Oh my god.
Actual little bitches.
Alright, am I washed, guys?!
Am I washed?!
Still washed.
Oh my god.
That shit was like... I was like, the fuck are you guys doing?
Fucking crazy... fucking little bitches.
I'm no longer washed.
We're so back.
What's your name?!
Oh yeah, Sunky Ray!
My chat called me washed, get shit on!
I'm gonna die here.
We're so back.
That's fucking right.
I shamed them.
Get 1v2'd by someone that hasn't played this game but still liked.
True gamers don't watch, we all know that.
I was like, the fuck are they doing?
Following me.
Holy shit, that's cringe.
Okay, I think the R9 is really good though.
Honestly.
I think the R9 is actually really, really good.
I don't know, it is my favorite gun.
So I know I can make plays with it.
Okay, I think I can third party this.
I just have to play like a fucking rat.
I always have to third party, or I die.
I saw somebody in front of me.
Oh, you see that guy?
I'm...
You see that guy that's trying to rat?
Oh shit.
Oh no.
No, I didn't even saw!
Fuck, I...
I fucked...
I don't know why I keep...
I keep thinking my Q is like an escapability.
I keep thinking my Q is my Z.
I was looking at the rat and then the other rat was looking at me.
It was like, we were just two rats looking at each other.
Yeah, I keep thinking my Q is my Raze Q.
I hear somebody next to me.
No.
No, no, no, no!
He's buddy!
No, no!
I got dead slide!
Oh, fuck!
I got a dead slide.
Oh my god.
Oh, unlucky.
My dead slide fucked me over.
Okay, but like, I'm getting there.
I'm figuring.
I'm clearing.
Like, oh my god!
I got a dead...
The dead slide is when your slide gets caught.
So that your slide gets caught and you don't have a smooth movement.
So like, I literally got dead slide twice during that.
And I could have like, got out because of it.
Oh my god, that fucking sucks.
I actually could have killed 1v2 them if I didn't dead slide.
Yeah, I lost my momentum.
Yeah.
I got stun-locked.
My leg got stuck.
Yeah.
Tommy Longlock, follow kill leader.
Follow me.
There's two rookies and 34 bronze.
That's me!
Yeah, no, I could have 100% 1v3 them.
1v2 those two.
If I didn't get the dead slide, it was so easy.
Oh my god.
So close.
I think RNI Massive is the way to go.
If I'm playing Ashe.
I'm pretty sure.
Holy shit, who are those fucking...
Six people not in.
It's not us.
I have Tommy Longlock and follow kill leader.
Follow me.
How about not whiffing those?
We don't talk about those.
Look, everyone...
Look, not everyone...
Me missing those shots means I'm human, okay?
You could have snared them?
Yeah, I know.
I could have snared them.
I don't play Ashe that often.
So I forget my abilities.
If I don't play a character that often, I forget to use my abilities and just rely on aim.
Which sometimes doesn't work out for me.
Alright.
Will I have an actual team or will I have silver teammates?
Oh hey, it's King's Canyon.
I love this map.
Alright, let's find out guys.
Will I have real teammates or will I have silver teammates?
Do I trust him?
We'll see if I do.
We'll see.
Let's see.
I want to grab the energy arsenal.
Bro.
I guess the real bro experience right there.
But still.
Bro.
I'll just grab these two.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I didn't mean to drop down.
I'm gonna get this.
Holy shit, Tommy Longzock.
You're going straight in.
You're fucking crazy, Tommy Longzock.
Where's the Val?
I literally saw him drop down.
There's one.
How'd the door shut?
I didn't do much.
Do it.
Oh my god.
There we go.
This feels a lot easier.
This game does feel a lot easier now.
Wow.
I guess I'll do ultimate.
I don't feel like I need the scream.
To be like that.
I wanna get... I want an R9.
Ping me.
Ping me R9.
Alright,
I just want an R9.
Until like I... that's all I want.
Alright.
Since I'm not Ashe, I don't need a play... I don't need a play master.
So I'll do... I'll do R9... I'll do R9 Nemesis.
Yeah, R9 Nemesis so I don't have to use two of the same ammo.
Alternator?
I'll take it for now.
He knows who the carry is.
And then he's gonna regret it.
I'm just gonna use my Q to get there faster.
That's fucking right.
I'm gonna use my Q just to get there faster.
Jesus Christ, it's so long.
It's so far.
I'm gonna get the R9.
Okay, there's a Carbine here too, but we don't need that.
Jesus Christ, where's my R9?
Somebody open this right now or I'm gonna fucking freak out.
Where's my Ashe?
Go do your thing, Ashe.
Alright, let's go.
That's fucking right.
What?
Why?
Why go over here?
Alright.
Alright, I guess I'll go over here.
I don't like that.
Bro!
Fucking bro!
Un-gas yourself now!
What the fuck is wrong with your stomach?
Please.
He's giving comms though!
The true bro experience.
Get yourself a bro that's willing to burp on mic for you.
It's like you're playing Atlanta right now.
I beg you, please mute him.
I like how he's asking us, the bronze players.
He's asking us, the bronze players, if we know.
Alright, I just need to have zero attachments on this gun.
I'll put my stock on the R9, I guess.
I'm literally right behind you!
Where's the bridge?
I'll go this way then.
And get high ground.
Better not be lying, because I'm on high ground.
There you go.
I got him.
I got him!
Bro, are you okay?
Are you okay?
Can you not get up on there?
Can you not climb up this?
Fuck, okay.
I thought I could hide through that.
There's Tommy Longzock.
Oh, that is very cocky.
I was like, really?
Bro, use your brain, bro!
Where was he?
Bro, what?
That was... oh man, that was... I shouldn't have pushed.
I thought he was going to climb up, but he didn't.
He's so weird.
I literally can't trust the team.
I climbed up, because I thought he was going to climb up, when I climb up.
And then I shot them for like 5 full seconds, and he still didn't climb up.
I was like, okay, I'm going to aggro them, and then he's going to shoot them in the back.
But he didn't shoot them in the back, so I'm so confused.
That's too... I know, I need to remember to play like not a team.
This is bronze.
I keep playing as if we're a team, you know?
But I have to remember, I cannot play like that.
Like...
I need to remember to set my expectations so fucking low.
I have to remember that.
Oh my god.
I need to remember, there's no team here.
There's no team here.
I was like, alright, I got the aggro.
You can shoot them in the back.
Do me some back shots.
He didn't do the back shots, guys.
Okay, Doki.
Play as if you're a solo player, Doki.
Like, you can't trust no one.
You gotta play like you're by yourself and alone.
That's how the world works now.
Oh man, the closest crafter is that cage.
That's why I would've dropped down if I knew that he wasn't gonna shoot them.
God, my head is too much.
Now I know that they're gonna play like silver players.
I don't know.
I was like, are they gonna play like a team or are they gonna play like silver players?
Leave,
just crap.
Just crap.
Bro, what is he doing?
He could just crap.
They're not following nobody, bro.
Why did he watch for so long?
He legitimately could've just crapped at us.
He did not have to wait.
Watch, I'm gonna crap you and you're either not gonna do anything or I've been following you.
We'll see, bro.
We'll see.
Resist.
Just resist.
Oh my god.
He didn't even pick up the craft.
He didn't pick up the res beacon.
He didn't pick up the res beacon that cost him a crafter.
Oh my god, and he gets the havoc.
Oh, thank god he gets the res beacon.
Oh my god, just res.
Just, just, oh my god.
Bro, why?
Okay, play like a solo, Doki.
You better do something, bro.
Play like a solo.
I gotta play like a solo.
I gotta...
I gotta play like I have no buddy anymore in my life.
Oh my god.
Aww.
Aww, Mupi.
What do you mean, I'm not kidding.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Oh my god.
Gosh.
Bro, this is so weird, bro.
Okay, play like a solo.
Play like a solo.
Oh my, these guys.
Bro, why, how is he crashing out in silver?
I don't understand.
How are you crashing out that badly in a bronze silver lobby?
That's actually crazy.
And then I don't even get a third player.
I don't even get a third.
Oh my god.
Oh thank god he exists, Doki.
I was gonna be like, I don't...
Oh my god.
Okay, play like a solo.
Play like you have no one to rely on, Doki.
Play a good old solo experience.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna get a cough drop.
I'll be right back.
Yeah, I'm back.
Do you think my team will be okay?
Do you think...
Do you think they'll be okay?
I don't know.
I don't know if my team will be okay this time.
I think we can win a game.
How are we landing?
That's so far.
Why is this so far?
Oh my god.
We're landing so far.
I'm gonna grab the elite ammo.
I'm grabbing my R9.
I'm wearing R9 Mastiff.
It's... Now it's bronze.
So it should fall.
The next ring is far.
Do not get caught outside of it.
I'm under fire.
One minute.
We have significant ground to cover.
I'm checking here just to see if we drop down.
No.
I hear... Oh!
Oh no, this is bad.
We're cornered, right?
What?!
Oh my god!
Wait, where's our third?
Oh, there he is.
Okay.
I was like, is our third gonna be with us?
Okay, let's see where our third goes.
Okay, don't worry.
He can craft us.
Oh, if he crafts us, I'll get my R9 back.
Bro, the crafter is over there.
Bro, bro, bro, bro.
You can tell he's lost.
You can tell Saucy Drew is very lost, guys.
He is not okay right now.
He's...
I'm out of money.
I'm falling.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Don't be mean, Trey.
Oh my god.
I think I need more friends.
I definitely need more friends.
Oh my god.
This has not...
Relatable.
Pro plays like I do.
Don't.
Oh my god.
Don't even know what I just saw.
I don't even know.
Okay.
We can grab a Mastiff here.
This isn't looted, so...
Oh god.
What?
Wild red.
Yeehaw.
I need this.
Do I have any?
Okay, I do.
Okay.
I need to grab a Mastiff from this.
Where's the Mastiff?
Okay.
Enhance my Mastiff, sir.
There we go.
I got a bolt from that.
That's good.
Alright.
This is okay.
Okay, I'm leaving.
They can loot as much as they want, but I'm gonna grab a Harvester so I can get blue armor.
Okay, I think the extra thing is better.
Honestly.
The only issue is just the fact that I don't have...
I don't have...
I have a long range, so...
Remember, no teammates.
No teammates, Doki.
You cannot rely on anybody.
No teammates at all.
You're just a sad, lonely girl.
Lonely, Mr. Lonely.
I have nobody to call my own.
You have nobody.
The saddest game of my life.
Okay, let's throw this.
I have that.
If only he can pick up a controller and carry me right now.
I can upgrade my R9 here.
Actually.
Still got it.
I can still open doors.
At least I got that in me.
I just want to upgrade my R9.
Nice, I got my stock.
Oh.
Wait a minute.
There's someone here.
Hi there.
It's...
Oh wait, nevermind.
JK.
I forgot the storm can kill him.
It's JK.
JK.
I forgot that was a thing.
They usually...
In the past, it didn't.
In the past, the storm never... doesn't kill him.
I forgot that was something they added in King's Canyon.
For those like in the old King's Canyon, storm doesn't kill the dragon.
So like, you know, you wouldn't get like fucking paranoid.
And shit about it.
I was like, the fuck?
I don't hear any gunshots at all.
The storm is deadly?
Yeah, but then the dragons would like live forever in the storm.
Are you fucking...
Are you serious?!
They waited for us!
Oh
my god.
They actually wanted these fuckers.
Oh my god.
Like, how long were they waiting?
They must have waited for so long!
I like...
There was no...
There was no outplay.
There was actually no outplay for that.
Like...
There was...
There was no outplay potential!
How did like...
Like, three people ran in there and waited for me.
Oh my god.
I couldn't even outplay it.
I'm so sad.
That I had no...
There was no way to outplay that.
There was no outplay ability.
I literally just died.
Even...
Even if I...
Oh my god.
I couldn't even get my ult out in time because of it.
I could not get out of that ambush.
I even used my dash.
Oh my god.
If I got around the corner, I think I could've lived.
I could've lived.
I got around the corner.
I dashed to the corner.
And then...
They like ambushed me in such a perfect time.
That like...
It was such a perfect ambush because I was too far deep into that line.
I can't...
There was no way for me to get out of there.
Like, even if I Q instantly, I die.
That was actually crazy.
It was just...
They waited at the perfect moment.
I heard...
I heard the ballistical and I turned around.
I...
I even...
I even went with the sound Q.
Oh my god.
What are you doing here?
That was actually crazy.
Just...
Just hot drop me.
I don't care.
It's bronze.
I'm tired of running around.
Just hot drop me.
Just hot drop.
I'm tired.
I'm so fucking tired.
Just hot drop.
Just fucking hot drop.
I'm so fucking tired.
At least take me to containment.
At least...
No!
You're bronze!
You don't need to play this!
You don't need to play!
Oh my god.
Okay.
You don't need to play!
Don't be like this.
We're...
We don't...
Let me out.
Let me...
At least land here.
And then we can third party this place.
At least...
At least land me there.
Like, that's all I want.
We're gonna...
We are...
Are we...
Yeah.
They're gonna get R9 from this.
Are we fighting for...
No, we're not.
They're not.
We're not fighting for this.
Okay, that's good.
That's good.
That's...
That's fine.
At least we're not...
I'm okay, guys.
I'm okay.
I'm...
I'm okay, guys.
Oh, shit.
That's not what I...
I'm okay.
I'm not crashing out.
I'm not crashing out, guys.
I'm okay.
Let's just run triple take, too.
I don't know if triple take is still good.
Honestly.
Oh, wait.
I'll just run massive.
Fuck it.
I'll run long...
I'll run short range.
With how they're fucking me, I might as well run short range.
Oh my...
I'm okay, guys.
I'm okay.
I am 100 positive.
Okay.
Okay, I got my mag.
You guys wanna fight?
Are you guys fighters?
Do you guys wanna fight?
Are you...
Are you guys...
Are you guys fighters?
You guys wanna fight?
Guys!
Are you guys gamers?
You guys wanna fight?
Yeah?
Alright, we're fighters.
Alright, let's see.
I'm not going first.
I don't trust my fucking team.
I'm never going first again.
After...
After the last game, I'm never going first again.
Go!
They're third partying.
They're literally in front of me.
Go!
Shoot them!
Guys!
Go!
He's literally right here.
We shoot this guy...
This team.
We pincer them.
Okay.
I'm gonna go...
I'm gonna get an off angle.
Okay.
Just crawl.
Wait, where's the...
Where's the other guy?
I'll cover.
This is a different team.
This is two teams.
So...
I wanna go for the team to the left.
Or right.
Oh!
Stupid.
Holy shit.
You're so stupid.
You're actually so stupid.
Where did the box go?
Really?
You're gonna run?
What?
I hear him.
I hear this guy.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I'm going for it.
I'm going for this kill.
I'm already committed to it.
Okay.
Cool.
Alright.
Okay.
This is what I'm gonna do.
I am gonna...
Where's the closest crafter?
I'll go this way.
Alright.
This is what I'm gonna do.
I guess this is...
Okay.
Alright.
Let's do this.
In the zone we go.
Okay.
I'm not gonna use my redeploy yet.
I'm gonna go here.
I'm gonna craft them.
And then I'm gonna use my redeploy.
And redeploy the containment.
And then I'll...
I shouldn't use my Q, but fuck it.
Like, why would you not commit to that kill?
Like, you might as well.
There's no point in being a little fucking bitch.
Oh my god, I guess...
Off I go.
Oh, let's hope there's nobody crafting there.
I heard some noises I don't like.
Alright.
I either die or live.
We'll see here.
I have to craft them there.
And then I take a redeploy and go to containment.
And I'm either gonna die from...
Oh wait, no.
Actually...
Okay, I can craft...
Actually, I can...
I can do this.
I forgot I can craft it.
Do I...
I thought I heard...
I did hear something.
Oh
fuck, okay.
Okay, I can craft them.
Alright.
Alright, here's the plan.
The next crafter is over there.
Okay.
Oh my god, there's too many people here.
Oh, there's too many people here!
Okay.
Fuck, okay.
This is a little hard.
I gotta sneak in then.
Maybe they pushed up.
They pushed up.
Pushed up.
I had to get rid of that, so...
Is there a crafter?
There's no fucking...
Okay.
Alright, this is gonna be the riskiest shit I ever play... do... done.
I take a reapply.
And then we'll see if I live.
And then we'll try and go there, I guess.
They won't see my trail if I do this!
There's people fighting there.
Okay.
Okay, maybe I can get a rez here.
What?!
I can't even get a Q out!
Are you serious?!
There's no... I can't even get a Q out!
When I get... Oh my god, the TDK is so fast.
The TDK is actually so fast.
Oh my god.
Like, you can't even press Q.
I had to get out of that.
Jesus.
And it's this fast in Bronze.
Like, oh my god.
Didn't know you were playing.
God.
I think, like, if the TDK is that fast, I think...
I really think they need to lower the Wraith's Q time again.
Like, yeah.
Like, the Wraith Q has to be lowered.
Like, there's no... There's... It's actually, like, useless.
Her Q is so fucking useless.
I was like, I don't think Wraith's the play.
It's so... Like, her Q is just so fucking useless at that point.
TDK is time to kill.
And the fact that these were Bronze players shredded me that fucking fast.
When I can't even use her Q ability to even get out of it.
Yeah, I might try Bangalore.
Maybe.
If I can't...
I think Ashe, right now, is really good for escape ability with her dash.
But, like, I honestly think that...
It's either I play Ashe or Bangalore, I think.
I keep thinking it, like, Q, it would be easier.
But, it's not.
Oh my god.
Yeah, Ashe is definitely good against this time to TDK.
But, like, playing Wraith...
Playing Wraith, it was just so fucking rough.
Playing Wraith with that.
Yeah, I might try Bang if I don't get Ashe.
I'm gonna fucking insta-jump.
Insta-land.
Like, I'm tired of...
Uh, we'll do...
We'll do...
Let's see, we'll do...
I'm going Capacitor.
I'm fucking going Capacitor.
I'm done with...
I can't.
I can't run around.
We either die or we get kills.
Let's get here.
I wanna land here.
I need that R and I.
Okay.
Jesus Christ, that TTK.
That TTK was absolutely fucking brutal.
Holy fuck.
Alright, I'm coming over.
Oh my god.
Okay, I'm coming over.
You crawl fast.
You should be...
There you go.
You're welcome.
I got one of them down for you.
And I knocked one of them down for you.
You're welcome.
Alright, this is a little bad for me because I have no shield cells left.
Okay.
Where are they?
Where's the other guy?
What?
Oh, there he is.
I was like, where is he?
He ran, yeah.
I was like, where did the other guy go?
I didn't get a chance to upgrade my R and I because I had to save this fucker.
Oh, this is a new team.
This is a new team.
Oh no.
Fuck, there was no way.
Oh my god, we got thirded.
The sound is even worse this season.
That's good to know.
Cool.
Oh man, whole squad and only heard one.
Yeah, we lost one guy instantly.
That was unlucky.
Jesus Christ, this game got a lot harder.
I need to lock it in.
I just want one.
Okay.
Alright guys, I'm gonna lock in.
I can't fuck around anymore.
I need to lock in.
I'm gonna lock in guys.
Alright, serious derky time.
Serious derky time.
Alright.
This is it.
This is fine.
I can be serious.
I can be serious now.
I can fucking do this.
Guys!
I can do this.
I need you guys to believe in me.
I also need you guys to believe in me too, guys.
Guys, I can't do this without you guys.
You guys gotta believe in me too.
Give me your energy.
That was unlucky though.
We're going straight down.
I can't be bothered.
I cannot be bothered.
We're going fucking straight down.
We're in bronze.
If you guys cry about landing straight down, get a high ELO.
I cannot be bothered.
You don't even lose anything.
We're just here to fight.
I need out of here.
Oh, my random isn't even alive.
My random isn't even alive, guys.
She's not locked in.
She's not even locked in.
She's not even here.
It's already over before we even landed.
What the fuck?
Oh, man.
That's rough.
Our random's down here.
Is she still AFK?
Okay, guys, this is not the match.
Guys, I realize this might not be the match where we're locked in.
Our third isn't even alive.
Alright, thank you!
Our third isn't even alive!
Oh, my God.
Lord, grossest.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, I guess we leave, I guess.
Who would've thought we're just gonna leave like that?
I wanna fight them.
I think we can fight.
No, nevermind.
My other guy cannot fight this.
Nevermind.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
This is all of my current energy.
Guys, I have a feeling that my third can't do this either.
There it is!
I was hopeful until, like, you know...
Until I saw him get absolutely demolished.
Okay, they're flying to us.
Let's see.
I'm gonna try and fight this.
Okay.
They actually wanna fight, fight.
Where are they?
Behind me.
Okay, you cannot- Oh my god.
I'm trying to figure out where they are.
Okay.
They're just taking, like, 20 different off-angles.
Like, what the fuck?
Oh my god.
THIS IS ANOTHER SQUAD?!
Okay.
You're such a fucker.
You're actually- You're such a- Oh my god.
If I wasn't 1 HP, I'd kill this guy.
I had no third.
And then we get- AND THEN THEY LIVE?!
WHAT?!
They live.
THEY LIVE!
My third being AFK sealed it.
Okay, now, this should be the game where I can lock it in.
This should be the game where I lock it in.
There is no god.
GOD WILL SHOW UP FOR THIS GAME.
Alright.
Valdo, thank you- I need to remember to use my Q.
My Q is what's been killing me a lot, too, because I keep forgetting to use Q and stuff.
Valdo, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Hey Doki, for my birthday today, I wish for you to continue being the best of the best and for you and Mint to prove you're the best duo in YouTuber history.
Also, please don't doubt yourself and make your success persist.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Valdo.
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Okay, we lock in.
This is where we actually lock in.
This is- This is it.
Give me- Give me capacitor, because they- Okay, I'm going to go for capacitor, because there's a light.
I need that light ammo.
Sticking bin.
I'm literally just doing this for light ammo.
That's really it for the light guns.
For guarantee R9, I don't fucking care about anything else.
Legit, I'm just- I'm literally just going in for the R9.
It sucks I don't have like a jump animation for Ashe, though.
I need this R9, I need this R9, I need this R9.
Legit, I'm only going for R9s.
Okay, here we go.
Oh my god, I'm getting better at using her jumps, though, at least.
I need to learn how to use her fucking Q.
That's like- That's been like my- Oh, I need a room to upgrade to.
Let me upgrade my light gun.
Give me my upgrades, give me my upgrades!
I'm going to make sure there's nobody.
Nice!
Enhanced.
Do I have any grenades?
I do.
I don't want to run Carbine R9, though.
But if I have to...
I'll put this here.
There's no long range gun I want.
I mean, I could grab the Mastiff.
I'll grab the Mastiff.
The blue bar is my dash cooldown.
Wait, what?
Where's- Where is- Here?
I'm looking for you.
Trying to cover for him.
I don't know if they're going to push, though.
I don't think they're going to push now.
Okay, guys.
Guys, chill, chill.
I'm literally here to- I'm literally here to, like, back you guys up.
Oh my god.
That was such a good shot from them.
Jesus Christ.
Wait, these guys are crazy.
Fuck, okay.
Oh,
I'm one- No!
Oh my god!
I was- He already got headshot on me.
I couldn't do anything.
He was insane on the wing.
That guy was insane on the wing, man.
I was too far.
Trying to get that cross angle.
Yeah, we did not live that.
That guy hit, like, three wingman shots on me.
Like, I was not living because there's no helmets anymore.
That guy was insane.
He hit three wingman shots.
He did three wingman shots on me, and we had no helmet, and I was like, I can't heal this in time.
No heals.
No fucking heals for that.
I think, like, if our lifeline didn't get knocked, it would have been doable.
But she got knocked first, so that was bad.
It's better or worse?
I think it's worse.
I've always hated lower- My biggest gripe?
I've always hated video games that have very low TTK.
Because, like, there's less outplayability.
There's less outplayability, and it just makes it feel like Call of Duty.
Like, it might as well just be, like, COD slash Battlefield.
And, like, I never- I don't like that.
No room to adapt.
Yeah.
Like, legitimately, I just got- I got three tapped by a wingman, and I couldn't play the game.
Like, I peeked that guy for one second, and...
I looked at that guy for one second, and then I had to heal.
Yeah.
So, like, it was just not it.
It was over after that.
I never, like- That's why I don't like tactical shooters.
I've hated tactical shooters, because the short TTK is just very frustrating.
Because there's no outplayability for it.
I'm just going for anywhere that has light ammo.
Yeah, like, I- It sucks, because there's literally zero play- Like, it's hard to adapt.
That's, like, the hardest part.
When you can't adapt to a situation.
We will get the light gun!
We won't get it first, guys.
We won't get it first.
I'm sorry.
I left them to die.
I got- I still got an R9, though.
I might have left them to die, but I got an R9.
Like, look at that!
Literally, so fast.
So fast.
Um, where's that guy?
Crawl!
Just crawl!
What are you doing?!
Okay.
Bro, this guy's fucking stupid.
Yoshi, I'm sorry.
You're not.
Thank you, Carl.
If you were sorry, you would have crawled so I could have rez you easily.
Alright.
That's right.
This is your first- Look at that.
This was his first fucking impression for me.
And he didn't- He stayed in the fucking open and forced me to punch him to cover.
You think a punch is gonna stop anything?!
You think apologies stop the war?!
No, it didn't!
And he took the massive, too?!
I need to wait for the massive.
There you go.
Alright.
He's already got my massive.
It's too late.
There's no more forgiveness.
I don't- I can't forgive anymore.
I know!
I have a massive.
There is no mercy.
If he fucks up one last time, I give him one more chance and then this is what's gonna happen.
He has one more chance to impress me.
And then this is what's gonna- Apparently it's a dragon.
Or that's gonna happen.
Alright.
One last chance.
I have to take cover so fast.
Because the TTK is so fast.
I legitimately- I can't even like- I feel like I can't even like- I don't wanna ult there.
I feel like it's so dangerous to ult there.
I've ulted high ground.
Alright.
I either die for this or I do like a quick-
That TTK is so fucking crazy.
Holy shit.
My team is already almost dead.
My team is almost dead already.
What the fuck?
What the fuck is going on?
Another squad?
Okay, this is another team.
Okay.
This is a new team.
I'm sorry, Horizon.
I'm so sorry.
I'm not fighting this.
This is a new team.
I'm just gonna go straight to crafting.
You better die so I can- Okay, there we go.
Like- I was like- Two teams?
Yeah.
That ain't it.
There we go.
Welcome back.
I heard two teams and I was like- Yep.
This is where we're gonna die.
I'm just gonna go to zone.
I'm not fight- I'm not fighting in zone.
Like, fuck that shit.
I'm not fighting in zone.
I'm not crazy enough for that.
I'm going to enhance my R9 though.
Oh, I hope they have enough meds.
I hope they all have enough meds for this.
Cause it'd be a shame if they- They might not.
Actually, I think my team might die in zone.
I think.
They might die in zone.
Whoops.
My bad.
I don't think they do have enough meds.
Yeah, there's no way.
I don't think they do.
Yeah, no, they don't.
They don't.
There's no way.
I'm gonna live.
I know who's living.
And it's me.
Oh shit!
No, wait!
Wait!
Wait, let me live first!
Let me- And it's me.
It's still me.
It's still me, by the way.
Yeah, it's still me.
Karma real- It's still me though, by the way.
It's still me.
I still live.
I just don't have meds.
But it's still me.
Spoke too soon.
It's still me, guys.
It's still me.
Maybe there's extra meds here.
I'm surprised they found enough syringes.
Where the fuck do they find all these syringes?
Oh, nice.
We still live.
This has been the most scuffed game of my life.
I feel like a medic more than an actual player.
I hear gunshots there and I really want- I have one syringe so I'm not giving them that syringe.
Wait, we're missing one person.
See, I can get this kill.
Or do you think I'll die?
Time to find out!
This way.
I thought they were closer.
Nice.
He's dead.
Linganark star.
He says when he's dead.
Over there.
I think I can surprise them.
What the fuck?
I don't even see a health registry.
You guys see that?
There was no health registry for that.
That was weird.
Yeah, I can do that too!
Yeah, I can do this!
And then my horizon died.
Okay.
I did not expect my horizon to die, but that's okay.
It's all about happy surprises, I guess.
Oh shit.
Fuck, they're over there.
Okay, that's cool.
That's... yeah.
I don't know about that.
This is a little awkward for me.
They're just gonna re-deploy.
They don't care.
We can take their re-deploy.
I'm gonna take their re-deploy.
Okay.
This is the only thing I can do to outplay this.
I might die though, but we'll see.
I'll run to the right side.
No, I'm dead.
That's fine.
Come on, please.
Alright.
That's how you use movement!
Open that, open that, open that, open that.
Grab this.
Okay.
I gained an extra dash, actually.
Oh wait, our guy died.
Okay.
Let's see if I can grab some heals.
Bro, you just noticed.
Okay.
Let's see if we can craft him.
Go craft this fucker.
Alright, I got the craft.
Res this guy, res this guy.
Why is our guy right here?!
I thought you were gonna be at the res beacon!
Alright.
Oh my god, okay.
Okay.
Look at that TTK, that's actually bullshit.
That's actually so sad.
Fuck!
That's crazy!
That should not be in the TTK, holy fuck.
That should not be my TTK.
That's insane.
That's so broken, that's so broken.
I can't, that's actually so fucking broken.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah, let's keep it.
It's way too cranked up, it actually is.
It's way too insane for...
I feel like it's just way too strong.
IMO.
Oh, okay.
Just take the evac, I'll just walk.
It's fine.
I walk, you guys take it.
30 seconds before the ring closes.
Use it well.
Yeah, the moment I looked at him, he was just dead.
There was like...
I think there's someone to my right and I think there's someone to my left.
I'm gonna go left.
Or I go left and then right, because they have an Octane, so...
Okay, so...
Hmm, alright.
Hmm, they're rezzing right now.
I'm trying to figure out how to play this.
I have... do I have two?
Let's see, I have two charges, maybe.
Umm...
They're over here.
This is insane.
Come on, come with me.
Now we're behind them.
Stop!
Why are you in front of me?!
Why did you stand in front of me?!
I'm not winning this back!
I'm so...
Oh my god!
That was your last chance!
That was...
I'll give you one more chance!
I had you stand in front of my shots!
He got... he took all my back shots!
That's actually crazy.
It's like...
Okay, let's see.
This is... zone.
This is zone.
And you know where they're gonna head to.
But they have people there too.
Fuck, okay.
I need to figure out how to maneuver this properly.
I have the ult to maneuver this.
But...
The hard part is that...
This is hard because they're all...
Let's see, they're not in zone though.
They're literally not in zone.
If I take... okay.
I might do something incredibly crazy.
And I could go all the way here.
Let's see.
No, they're already here.
Never mind.
They're already here.
I can't.
They're all like...
Oh my god, this is difficult.
They're all literally in the zone for...
Let's see, I'm trying to figure out where to go.
Okay.
We couldn't push that because this team is here.
Oh, I need to figure this out.
These guys are dumb as fuck for doing this.
I'm just gonna wait for the other team to push up.
Oh.
No, no, fuck!
I queued into zone.
I queued into...
Res me, res me, res me, res me right here.
I can't believe I queued in.
I queued into the zone.
Oh my god, I got two of those.
1v2.
I can't believe I actually queued into the zone.
It's 1v1, it's a 1v1.
I was like trying to figure out where the area was.
Alright.
Havoc is broken as fuck though.
I'm fucking running in.
Okay.
The Havoc is so dumb.
The Havoc is actually so dumb.
Holy shit.
He didn't look at me one time and everyone's dead.
It's so dumb.
Oh my god.
I think it really...
I just need a Havoc.
That...
If like I can do that.
If I could do that with a Havoc.
And like...
Like...
And I'm like super washed.
That...
Imagine if like a controller player, pro player holds a Havoc.
That's...
Holy fuck.
That gun is busted as hell.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
I literally...
1v...
Like...
I literally like 1v3'd a Havoc.
And all I did was just stayed on high ground.
Oh my god.
The damage output is insane.
Yeah.
Oh my...
Okay.
We did it guys.
We fucking did it.
We got it.
That gun is...
That gun is busted as fuck.
That gun is so busted.
Yeah.
More follows.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It reminds me that launching season 6 also has the same issue.
Hope they have fixes like when they did in that season 2.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Gaming.
Thank you for the 5 gift wishes.
Thank you.
Fire.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Nice win after the fumble.
That's our Doki mess up.
And...
And I Q'd into the zone.
I was like...
I'll be safe.
And then my...
My Z was like...
Wait a minute.
That Z is going a little too far.
I was like...
Wait a minute.
I saw myself go into the red.
And I was like...
Oh no.
And then like the...
That's when you know you fucked up.
Thank you for the 10 gift wishes.
Thank you.
Yeah, I went in a little too far.
See, welcome to Tomeo5.
Welcome.
Oh, yep.
It's gonna end it on a win.
We finally got that win.
Like I said, honest opinion.
I hate the fact that they lowered the...
I hate the fact that they lowered the time to kill.
Because...
Because it's...
I don't know.
It just...
I feel like it makes the game...
Just...
It's just so hard.
It just makes the game much more harder.
Because there's no...
I feel like it's really hard to outplay.
It's just...
It just feels like Call of Duty slash Battlefield.
Which I understand.
Because they want more fights.
They really want more fights.
But if I peak one second and I'm fucking out of the game.
Like I...
It's just not fun.
Like I don't wanna just be healing all the time.
Yeah.
Like if there's no...
Like if you're not the first person to initiate.
Then like you lose.
Like I literally...
I peaked my head one time and I was like...
What time to heal?
I feel like...
I know a lot of people are now playing...
What's that game called?
Delta Force?
Was it Delta Force?
Where it's the similar?
Because I think they're trying...
I know like Delta Force is getting really popular as well.
For people who like to play Call of Duty and stuff like that.
But I feel like...
I feel like...
You know...
Apex can be it's own game.
With it's own like...
You know...
Basically you can...
You can like...
I feel like there should be more availability.
I really do.
Right Chris?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thanks for the character.
Oh you liked your back shots.
I didn't.
I could've got a kill there.
Thank you for your very first super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
It feels like Valorant.
Yeah, that's why I never liked tactical shooters.
Just cause I...
Just cause I hate...
I like games where you can live longer.
That's basically it.
But like...
Ash is fun.
I would admit.
Ash is really, really fun to play.
I would say that.
I enjoyed that.
I just...
I...
I just didn't enjoy how I felt like I was playing Healing Simulator.
Like it definitely rewards positioning a lot.
Cause like I had to like stop being like stupid.
Like I had to...
I had to actually play...
Like I had to play like a fucking rat more.
So...
So like that's what like...
I had to change my play style.
Cause like I couldn't...
I couldn't like misposition.
Because the moment I mispositioned it was fucking over.
Um...
But yes, anyway.
Before I go.
Let me show...
Um...
The Doki Bird X Gina Draws collaboration merch collab.
This merch sale is gonna end in two weeks.
Um...
So please check it out.
Get the pajama set as well as the little eye mask.
It only...
It's only on sale for two weeks guys.
Two weeks.
Pre-order now, now, now.
Buy my merch.
Yeah!
I didn't forget that shit this time.
Anyway.
We have a membership stream tonight.
So as always everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around.
Get that blood flowing.
And if you sit up for me.
Head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye!